phyto Frankenstein never wanted to come
back to Germany but the 94 year old
returns to Berlin several times a year
traveling all the way from Stockholm it
was here that he was branded a Jew here
that he was a forced laborer it was here
that he and his young family survived
the Holocaust
this is what I had to wear and this is
what I was later given to wear the medal
is for my work with young people to do
my bit to ensure democracy in Germany is
maintained he's proud of his Order of
Merit medal but he is long called for
honors for those who risked their lives
to protect him and other Jews in Nazi
Berlin there's been even my ovum the
lives of my entire family on tylium
shoulders if it were not for them we
would not have survived
Hans danke a famous actor was one of
those who risked everything to help
voter and his cousin on screen he often
played the ladies man but during the
Holocaust he took on a different role in
the early 1940s he worked with the
lawyer Heinz good Slav to hide several
Jews they put their lives on the line
providing places to stay and fake
passports the Holocaust Remembrance
Centre Yad Vashem has now honored them
posthumously as Righteous among the
Nations
dear volta ever since I've known you and
it's been a number of years now you've
told me sooner should be honored Thank
You Volta without you we'd probably not
be here from Israel's ambassador to
Germany Jeremy ISA Kirov presented the
medals and certificates for the
relatives of those honored it was almost
overwhelming
[Applause]
I'm only here because I happen to be
related to hands on curve but I'm very
grateful to have this great person as
part of my family history only a few of
the estimated 7,000 Jews who hid in
Berlin survived the Nazi era vitae
Frankenstein is thought to be the only
one who made it with his whole family
Han Sankar immediately plucked up his
courage and helped us from the start
with clothes food and somewhere to stay
I get this fear failure there are four
pillars on which survival is built this
impudence no fear good friends and great
luck when he look he says the struggle
now is to defend democracy against
populism he wants to take an active part
in German politics by applying for a
German passport so he can vote here